are you doing today I'm doing great how
are you guys good man um right off the
bat want to ask you you you were kind of
hinting that you may be back that this
may not be the end last night as soon as
you got out of the pool or are you done
oh you know I and my swimming career on
that note there's so much more than I
want to accomplish in this course honey
so I'm not done yet but I'm definitely
gonna take a mental break and just let
my body recover in my mind and then get
back into it what is old for a swimmer
like is there an age now that it's old
for a swimmer because I we we see the
kazakh going well into the 32nd i think
it was like four years ago for me um but
you know i think it's uh it's different
things that you have to do outside the
pool um to help you recover help you
maintain the just like the salmon on the
body and everything and to prepare
yourself in nutrition you know
everything that starts taking play when
you get older so that's definitely going
to be my next chapter is taking my care
care of my body outside the pool leading
up to 20 20 hey Ron will you explain the
suction cup thing so we can all
understand it like what does it really
do uh you know what I never do it um I
don't want to leave hickeys on my body
so I I definitely don't do it on but you
know a lot of athletes so I know on in
particular Michael he he loves it on he
definitely houses anytime you have
soreness and you know a muscle
everything instead of always pushing it
down and out lift it up on the muscle
and I'll said break it apart on the
soreness known people like it I don't
Brian what do you do now you're done you
know once you finish competing what is
it like hanging
the Olympics the next couple of weeks
well um we definitely have to keep
cheering on USA on you know there's
still a lot more swimming sessions left
so we're definitely after going to get
behind on Team USA in this chairman and
then you know after swimming is all said
and done it's our time to you know go to
the beach have a nice cold Corona and
just relax run took a deeper hat on I
want to ask you you have you know
everybody tracking all the social media
dating apps going on in Rio you have a
you have a sweet little tinder profile
you have a couple of pictures on there
how's that going and have you been using
tinder um yeah yes I am on it but you
know my first and foremost thing my the
reason why I came here is this one so
you know I haven't really been able to
be on that social dating at all as much
as I should be I guess you know I had to
take care of a job first and that comes
first before so now that I'm done who
knows what will happen so you're saying
you'll get involved now now is the time
okay I'm done now I can focus on other
things how much fun is it being in the
Olympic Village like explain for mere
mortals that'll never cross into that a
low ground what is it like in the
Olympic Village you know it's it's
mainly you know you have everything the
dining hall you have all you can eat
McDonald's on arcade games like I mean
you have pretty much everything there
and the coolest thing is that you walk
around and you see people of your
caliber in different sports in different
countries it's just it's amazing where
it's one place in this whole entire
world where everyone comes together to
do one thing to compete at the highest
stage in sports I mean there's no other
better feeling than
alright will you do another reality
shore will you do anything in TV app you
know in the span while you're getting
ready for the next Olympic Games will
you go back to town you know i hope i
won't fun doing it i mean i didn't like
how has betrayed me found when i did it
but if that comes up again on doing
another reality TV show how would be
more than happy to do it because one
thing that i did get out of it is it
brought me and my family closer together
so if that opportunity comes up again
within the next four years i'll most
likely hear it again but by the way the
executive producer just texted me and
said they want to have you come in and
fill-in host for this the Dan Patrick
show would you fill in holes for the Dan
Patrick show oh sure why not I'm always
up for anything apparently all of the
danettes will wear speedos if you come
in they promised that they were were
speedos really it's been thrown out
there oh yeah yes I knew that would get
them in those guys were right real quick
up your hair what color you're gonna
change the color will you william died a
different color wiggle ice blue now well
it was it was supposed to be a light
bluish gray and then the chlorine got to
it and so it started turning green and
now i have this in blue conditioner to
try to turn it back to blue so who knows
where it's going it's a rollercoaster
ride i can keep up with it hey real
quick the moment for you the best moment
of these Olympic Games a moment where
you were like wow I can't believe I'm
here I can't believe this is happening
uh you know I think it definitely has to
be my very first individual gold medal
back into company not me just getting my
first individual gold medal in i think
it was when i got it i was able to turn
and saw my family in the stands and
seeing them the support that they've
showed me throughout all my years of
swimming
and just seeing the tears of their eyes
um and just happier happiness definitely
brought tears to my eyes and that's
something that I will never forget for
the rest of my life you know you and
Phelps are playing yourselves up as
these old guys but is there some
satisfaction in knowing that you could
go into your 30s and still give it to
these younger guys I mean I think the
person to really look towards that is
Dara Torres I mean was she competed in
08 she was she was 44 things yeah turned
orzo I mean there is no age limit um and
you know as long as you do certain
things take care of your body outside
the pool and be smarter in the pool you
can call as long as you want as long as
you're still having fun I think you can
keep going all right before you go gotta
ask you about the poll question we know
you're coming back but do you think
Michael Phelps will come back on you
know I was the only person that said
this back in two thousand twelve when he
city was retiring and that was right and
I'm going to say it again that he's
going to come back for 2012 I mean 2020
so I'm trying to tell the guys here no
way he gives it up you can't be that
dogs well I don't think I don't think
you know I don't think he'll give it up
I think he was because he knows I'm
gonna go for another four so any was
racing against me I could be doing the
best out of each other so I think you'd
want to get back in and just you know go
head-to-head in battle again all right
Ryan thanks so much for joining us Ryan
Lochte 12 Olympic medals end up truly
enjoy your real experience now go out
there and tear up Rio and don't forget
they expect you here to host the show
and the guys will be in speedos they
promised they will be in speedos what
about the girls give them a second they
have to figure out the whole girl back
they'll get some ladies in here for you
don't worry you take care of business in
the Olympic Village the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
you